PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today I'd like to talk to you
about some notable aspects of
Python that you'll encounter in
the 6.01 software, as well
as in the general sense when
working with Python.
A lot of these little tidbits
of Python have some
interesting history associated
with them, especially related
to the history of computer
science.
And also, I want to indicate
some things that tend to mess
up, especially, first time
programmers, but also
especially people that
are new to Python.
First, I'd like to bring
us back to last week.
We were talking about
object-oriented programming
and inheritance.
Object-oriented programming
is a programming paradigm.
It's in the same category as
imperative programming or
functional programming.
And you might say I have a good
sense of the fact that in
object-oriented programming,
everything is an object.
But I don't really have a good
sense of what constitutes
imperative programming or
functional programming.
I'm going to focus on functional
programming right
now, because it has more of a
historic root in the academic
development of computer
science.
Functional programming is like
object-oriented programming in
that everything is a function.
It refers to the idea that you
want to write as much of your
code as possible in a purely
functional manner.
And in particular, you're
looking for the ability to
avoid things like side-effects
or enable many different kinds
of evaluation.
Those kinds of things are not
the subject of this course,
but I think they're worth noting
to figure out why we're
bothering learning about things
like lambdas and list
comprehensions in
the first place.
Speaking of which, the first
thing we need to talk about
before we even talk about things
like lambdas and list
comprehensions, is the concept
that in Python,
everything is an object.
But because functions are
first-class objects, we can
also treat Python to a large
extent like a functional
programming language.
What do I mean when
I say functions
are first class objects?
I mean that a function
can be the return
value of another function.
I mean that the function can be
passed in as an argument to
a function.
And I mean that functions can be
assigned variable names and
manipulated the same way that we
manipulate any other piece
of data structure.
This is important, because
if you want higher order
functions or functions that
actually modify or use other
functions as a part of you know,
whatever it is they do,
then you need to be able to
interact with the function
like it's any other object,
in part pass it in
or return it out.
Let's look at an example.
So let's say I start off with a
very basic function, right?
If you want to square some
sort of value, probably
numeric in this case, then
all you have to do is
multiply it by itself.
Pretty simple.
Good place to start.
As a consequence of the idea
that functions are first class
objects, I can write a function
that takes in a
function as an argument and
then develops a return
function that uses the
function that I
passed in, on itself.
So any arguments that I would
pass to someFunction, I would
pass into someFunction, take
the return value of this
function call, and then pass
that into someFunction again.
That's what returnFunction
does.
And down here, I return
returnFunction.
Note that the object
type of this
return value is a function.
So once I have returnFunction,
I can actually pass it
arguments, have them run through
someFunction, not once
but twice, and then get out a
value that's of the return
type of someFunction.
Note that I made some
assumptions while
writing this function.
First, I've assumed that
someFunction returns out the
same number of arguments, and
either accept an arbitrary
number of arguments or accepts
the same number of arguments
as it puts out.
The other assumption that I've
made is that the data type
that someFunction returns is
the same as the data types
that someFunction accepts.
Or the things that someFunction
does to its
arguments can be done to
multiple kinds of arguments.
But that's a whole different
argument.
Right now, we're just focusing
on the fact that we pass in
some arbitrary number of
arguments, call someFunction
on it, call someFunction again
on the return value of this,
and return that as something you
can do to whatever it is,
someFunction operates on.
OK.
Let's review an example, because
I promise it'll be
more clear.
Let's say f is going to be the
composition, a square on itself.
If I do that, I end up with a
function that operates on an
arbitrary number
of arguments--
that's not true.
I end up with a copy of square
that takes in the same number
of arguments as square
called on itself.
So here a square is substituted
for someFunction.
Here a square is called on
that call of square.
And here is what f
is assigned to.
So when I call f of
2, I'm going to
substitute 2 in for args.
I'm going to call
square on args.
If I call square on
args, I get out 4.
And if I call square on args
again, or if I call square of
args where args is defined as
the return value of this, then
I'm going to call square
on 4, I'll square 4,
and I'll get 16.
Take a second to type it into
IDLE, and make it make sense
to yourself.
All of this code
should compile.
Mess around with the parameters,
if you're having
trouble convincing yourself
that it does.
Ok.
Now I think we're ready
to talk about lambdas.
If you can pass in functions as
arguments or return them as
values or assign them to
variable names and just treat
them like any other data type,
then you should be able to
treat them as some sort
of raw value.
And that's where lambdas
come in.
Lambda is a key word in Python
that tells you you're about to
use a function that you have not
given any sort of name or
defined in any place in your
code or environment
beforehand.
You're just going to start
talking about something that
you would like to do to a given
number of arguments, and
then what you want
to return out.
Lambda has roots in lambda
calculus which, if you're
familiar with the history of
computer science, you've
probably heard of.
Now might be a good time to look
up lambda calculus, if
you've never heard it before
or possibly Alonzo Church.
But it's still available in code
today, which is really
cool, and speaks to the
continuing power or at least
recognition of importance of
functional programming.
As I said before, the idea with
lambda is that you could
write an anonymous function.
Over here, in order to write a
function that's squared, I had
to write out a define line.
And because Python uses
indentation, because in
Python, indentation carries
meaning, I'd have to enter and
return over to a next line--
I'm actually not sure if
that's strictly true.
I think you can do def
square x, return
x, but I'm not positive.
I've only seen it written
like this.
And I think it's because in the
general sense, people try
to respect things like
convention and
readability in Python.
If you're using lambda, people
already know that you want to
describe a function
really quickly.
Or you want to describe
function without
assigning it any name.
Therefore, the two most common
uses you'll see of lambda is
when you want a really fast
function and you don't want to
spend extra time or lines
writing out that function.
It's pretty clear what
this is going to do.
Or if, in a particular
sense, you need
an anonymous function.
You don't want to assign
a name or memory space
associated with that function.
Note instead of using square,
I can just write out this.
So I saved two lines of
code defining square.
And then I don't have to refer
back to some earlier part of
the code in order to understand
what this line does.
Pretty cool.
All right.
So there's functions of
first class objects.
There's lambda.
Let's talk about how to
use lambdas on lists.
In Python, you'll end up doing
a lot of list manipulation.
One of the best uses of
anonymized functions in any
functional programming language
is the ability to
manipulate lists in a line.
If I've defined just a pretty
straightforward list right
here, I can use functions like
map filter and reduce to--
in one line--
take a list, apply a function to
every element in that list,
and then return a copy of
the result of that list.
I didn't have to write a
separate function to do the
list handling.
I didn't have to write a
separate function to multiply
the list by two.
And I've communicated what I'm
doing effectively to people
that are used to functional
programming.
So if you type this line in,
you should end up with a
return in interactive mode of
every element in this list
multiplied by two.
Now's a good time to try.
Once you've done that, I also
recommend looking at the
original copied demolist.
Note that this is unaltered.
Map actually returned a new data
structure that represents
performing this function
on this list.
This becomes important later
when I explain aliasing, but I
will do that in about
two minutes.
If we want to get even more
elegant, we can use list
comprehensions.
List comprehensions--
if you ask somebody where list
comprehensions are from,
they'll probably say Haskell,
because that is the most
popular use of list
comprehensions, in terms of
pure lazy functional
programming.
But it actually goes back
further than that, and is in
Small Talk, and then something
from the '60s.
I can't remember the name
of it right now.
They're really nice because
they borrow a syntactic
approach from mathematicians.
This looks a lot like
set notation.
And when you read this, you
can probably tell that the
list listComprehension is going
to describe a set of
points from 1 to 4.
But you accomplish that in
possibly one line of code.
I've written it on three here
because I wanted to keep it in
this space.
But it's really concise.
If you type this into IDLE,
you should see the kind of
list that it returns,
and also what's
listComprehension is now--
what now constitutes
listComprehension.
You can use listComprehensions
with functions like map and
filter and reduce.
And, along with the anonymized
functions, all of these tools
provide you with a lot of
functionality in a very short
amount of space.
It's also good to be able to
recognize what's going on when
you see something like this
or something like this.
Because you'll probably run into
it in, in particular, a
lot with Lisp code, but also in
the artificial intelligence
community in particular.
Ok.
We've talked about all that.
Let's take a second to talk
about the fact that lists are
actually mutable, and what that
means, and what things
you have to be careful about if
you're going to be working
with mutable objects.
If you're new to programming,
or you're new to Python,
you've probably already
worked with some of
these data types, right?
Any numbers, any strings,
any tuples,
are going to be immutable.
What that means is if you have
a variable and you have a
second variable that has a
different assignment line
associated with it-- right?
I haven't assigned
g to h here.
I've just signed g to "hello"
and h to "hello."
If you look at the space in
memory that Python associates
with both objects, they point
to the same place.
This is the definition of
an immutable object.
When g points to "hello" and h
points to "hello," they both
point to the same place.
If x points to 5 and y points to
5, they're both pointing to
the same place.
If you point x at 6,
it now points to a
different memory address.
This gets confounded
when you're talking
about mutable objects.
The problem with mutable objects
is that you select a
memory space to contain the
object or memory ID in Python
to contain the object.
And then that object is
changed in place.
You can use this to your
advantage but it can
also mess with you.
And here's how.
Let's say I assigned
a to a small list.
And I also assigned b to a.
b and a now point at
the same place.
If I manipulate b, and I'm--
excuse me-- still working with
an immutable object, or excuse
me, if I'm still working with
a mutable object, the object
in that memory address
has been altered.
And b and a still point to
the same place in memory.
So if I look at a, it's going to
look like b, which is going
to look like 1, 2, 3, 4 --
which is not what I assigned
a to originally.
Again, can be powerful, but you
have to keep it in mind.
And it might start to mess with,
in particular, the 6.01
software when you're dealing
with state machines.
In order to get around this, you
can create a copy of the
list and then modify the copy.
This is actually
what map does.
If you want to do it, the
easiest way to do it on the
first layer is to specify
the index into the
list with no bounce.
It'll copy the whole thing.
There's also a Python library
copy or deep copy, if you want
to copy lists of lists of
lists of lists of lists.
And just to clarify, you'll note
that after you assign c
to a copy of a, c and a occupy
different memory places.
So if you modify c, a will
retain its original value.
I think that's all the
notable things I have
to say about Python.
and gives us enough power to do
some really powerful list
manipulation or array
manipulation, and covers what
we want to say about functional
programming before
we get into the notion
of state, which I'll
talk about next time.